hi everyone happy New Year and welcome
to CES 2023
I will Define the future of computing
and this has influenced much of what we
are covering today so let's get started
[Music]
last year proved challenging on many
fronts yet gaming left 2022 stronger
than ever
we added 20 million new pc Gamers to our
ranks and a hundred million since 2019.
steam Peak daily users reached a new
high of 32 million up 16 percent from
2021. Esports viewing hours increased 40
percent over the prior year the 2022
League of Legends Champions finals broke
a new audience record
and no one missed the Call of Duty
Modern Warfare 2 release which exceeded
800 million dollars in the opening
weekend
bigger than the combined openings of top
gun Maverick and Dr Strange in a
Multiverse of Madness
last fall we introduced a Quantum Leap
in PC gaming our Ada Lovelace
architecture Ada features Next
Generation Shader cores RT cores and
tensor cores and breakthroughs and
Graphics like Shader execution
reordering Ada also delivered a stunning
advance in neural Graphics AI will
change gaming forever every RTX GPU
comes bundled with a supercomputer
training AI networks to generate high
resolution frames from a lower
resolution base the AI inference is then
done in real time on RTX tensor cores
this is dlss with Ada we introduced the
next breakthrough in AI powered graphics
dlss3
dlss3 uses AI to generate entirely new
frames outside of the graphics pipeline
boosting game performance up to 4X over
Legacy rendering
for CPU limited games like Microsoft
flight simulator
dlss3 frame generation doubles the frame
rate and the super computer is always
running as we continue to enhance the
network to better understand different
classes of game content look for our
next dlss3 update later this quarter
DLS S3 momentum is in high gear there
are over 250 release games and creative
apps that have turned to AI powered dlss
to boost performance and dlss3 is being
adopted by developers faster than any
prior Nvidia tag with 50 released or
soon to be released titles let's take a
look at dlss3 in action in some of
today's biggest games
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
and there is more to come which fire is
an upcoming Dark Fantasy first person
shooter from the astronauts a bafta
winning studio and the team behind
painkiller and Bulletstorm
I'm excited to announce that witchfire
will feature the AI performance boost of
dlss3 when it launches in early 2023
let's take a look at exclusive new
gameplay of witchfire
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the day before is an open world MMO
Survival game set in a deadly
post-pandemic America overrun by flesh
hungry infected it's one of the top most
wishlisted games on Steam
today we are announcing the day before
we'll launch March 1st featuring Ray
tracing and dlss3
here's an exclusive look at the day
before with RTX on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
warhaven is a medieval fantasy sword
fighting experience by Nexon it will pit
teams of 16 players against one another
in brutal battles with blades bows and
Magic
today we are announcing that warhaven
will be accelerated by Nvidia DLS S3
when it launches later this year
here is an exclusive new look at
warhaven
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
throne and Liberty is a brand new IP
from ncsoft famous for universally
acclaimed MMORPGs including Guild Wars 2
Lineage 2 and Blade and Soul coming in
2023 RTX Gamers will jump into boss
raids with a performance multiplier of
dlss3 here is an exclusive reveal of
throne and Liberty
[Applause]
foreign
is one of the most anticipated games of
2023 where you take part in explosive
Encounters in a mad and Sublime utopian
world releasing February 21st RTX Gamers
will explore this Twisted sci-fi world
with dlss3
let's take a look at exclusive new
gameplay of atomic heart
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we built GeForce now to make high
performance gaming accessible to
billions of gamers
it is now serving more games to more
countries than any other gaming service
subscribing to gfn puts a GeForce RTX
GPU in any client including Chromebooks
phones low-end laptops even MacBooks 25
million members have enjoyed playing
over 1500 games including fortnite
gentian impact Far Cry and Apex Legends
with more games added each week on gfn
Thursday GeForce now continues to expand
globally through our network of partners
that now include rain Communications in
South Africa ytl Communications in
Malaysia and gfn.am in Armenia
I'm excited to announce that the Ada
Lovelace architecture is coming to
GeForce now the new RTX 4080 super pods
will deliver an amazing 64 teraflops of
Graphics goodness to each gamer that is
five times the performance of an Xbox
series X and will include full Ray
tracing and DLS S3 for competitive
Gamers we're also bringing Nvidia reflex
to gfn the RTX 4080 super pods can
render and stream at 240 frames per
second when combined with our reflex
technology it achieves click to pixel
latency below 40 milliseconds a first in
cloud gaming that is about half the
latency most console Gamers see
take a look for yourself
[Music]
the RTX 4080 will be available in our
new Ultimate membership which is
replacing our highest tier the RTX 3080
membership
only ultimate members will have
exclusive access to our highest
performance gpus and can stream at up to
4K and 240 frames per second RTX 4080
availability will start in select data
centers in late January with added
coverage across North America and
Western Europe throughout q1
all RTX 3080 members will receive the
Ultimate Upgrade and be among the first
to become ultimate members
and more exciting the price to existing
3080 members will remain the same just
19.99 a month
the GeForce RTX 4090 and RTX 4080
launched last fall delivering our
biggest leap ever in performance and
power efficiency the RTX 40 series
extended our leadership in graphics
including Ray tracing AI power dlss and
reflex for low latency Competitive
Gaming today I am excited to announce
our next GPU in the family the GeForce
RTX 4070 tie the RTX 4070 tie delivers
up to three times the performance of our
previous Flagship GPU the 3090 TI it
will max out your 1440p gaming monitor
delivering over 120 frames per second on
Modern games like a plague tail Requiem
Warhammer 40K dark tide F1 2022 and
Spider-Man Miles Morales with the power
of dlss3 the 4070 tie delivers 1.8 x
performance across a range of titles
while consuming almost half the power
the RTX 4070 tie is packed with 40
teraflops of ADA Shader cores 93
teraflops of third generation RT cores
and 641 teraflops of fourth generation
tensor cores it features dual av-1
encoders to double the performance of
video export the RTX 4070 tie will be
available on January 5th with a starting
price of 7.99
the rtx40 series is the ultimate GPU for
serious Gamers and creators the RTX 30
series continues to be the best GPU for
mainstream Gamers starting at just 329
Gamers and creators are turning to RTX
laptops to drive the most demanding
games and apps
the need for performance and portability
has fueled RTX laptop growth well beyond
the overall PC market
and now over one-third of G-Force users
are creating and there's more to come
with 60 percent of the GeForce laptop
installed base not yet upgraded to RTX
power and thermal constraints are the
ultimate challenges in delivering high
performance in thin highly portable
laptops with the Ada architecture we set
out to transform laptops through process
design and Technology the result is a
massive two-third reduction in power at
the same performance
put another way Ada beats our current
Flagship gpus with one third the power
today we are announcing that GeForce RTX
40 series laptops they are three times
more power efficient and bring the eight
architecture DLS S3 and new Max Q
Technologies to the next generation of
laptops across gaming and creating RTX
40 Series Laptops deliver up to four
times the performance in the most
demanding apps blowing away the previous
generation in Creative apps like blender
and Arnold and top AAA games like
cyberpunk 2077
for years we've worked with system oems
and CPU manufacturers to look beyond the
GPU to a full system design approach to
Performance and portability
we call it max-q we optimize every
aspect of the laptop the GPU CPU memory
thermal software display and more to
deliver powerful devices that are thin
and quiet with great battery life and
with every generation we have featured
new technologies that take laptops even
further today we are introducing four
new max-q Innovations
dlss3 has been optimized for laptops
built into all of our maxq Technologies
including whisper mode and Battery boost
improving the performance noise and
battery life by up to 2x we've partnered
with memory manufacturers to offer the
lowest voltage gdr6 ever shipped
and try speed memory control that
enables the GPU to switch to newer low
power memory States dynamically finally
Ada's on-chip memory has been optimized
for max-q doubling the bandwidth
increasing the size 16x and improving
clock gating our focus on laptop design
and Max Q has led to a massive 22 times
increase in efficiency over the past six
years
highly portable 14-inch laptops are
becoming the fastest growing form factor
over 13 million were sold last year
twice as many as in 2020 but 95 percent
of these laptops are only capable of
basic productivity tasks
thanks to the RTX 40 series 14-inch
laptops are transformed and able to take
on tasks never before possible like
Ultra Fast 3D rendering and blender or
Cutting Edge AI Tools in popular apps
like Adobe Photoshop or Premiere Pro
they are also gaming powerhouses up to
twice as fast as a PlayStation 5 but 1 6
the size you can play the latest AAA
games like cyberpunk 2077 with Ray
tracing and dlss
connect them to an external Monitor and
your 14 inch Ultra portable becomes a
desktop class gaming rig or Creator
Studio
today we are introducing the new RTX
4070 4060 and 4050 laptops faster than
our last generation Flagship laptops at
one third the GPU power delivering 80
frames per second 1440p Ultra gaming and
transforms creating like rendering
scenes in blender that used to take two
and a half hours to just 10 minutes on
RTX
40 Series Laptops start at just 9.99 and
will be available on February 22nd
the Ada architecture has also enabled a
new class of Enthusiast laptops I'm
excited to introduce today the new RTX
4090 and 4080 Flagship laptops
they start at 19.99 and will be
available on February 8th
these are the world's fastest Gamers can
play on up to three 4K monitors for
surround gaming at 60 frames per second
enough to power a professional grade
driving simulator
creators can use Nvidia Omniverse at 4K
for 3D design with full simulated
physics lighting and materials
live stream your games at 4K 60 frames
per second with av1 to Discord and Ada's
new dual Channel encoders cut video
export time in half
the RTX 40 series is our biggest launch
ever there are laptops coming from every
major OEM
with a huge variety of devices there is
an RTX laptop for every gamer and
creator
now I'd like to introduce Stephanie
Johnson our Global Marketing VP for
studio and cloud gaming
thanks Jeff Gamers demand the absolute
best performance but they are not alone
in those needs with over 110 million
professional and hobbyist PC creators
the market continues to grow fueled by
powerful technology
2D artists are moving to 3D from game
modders to graphic designers the growth
is staggering at 42 percent year over
year AI eliminates tedious tasks and
brings new assistance to the creative
process
and video workloads are moving to real
time from live streams to short form
videos like Tick Tock Nvidia studio is
our platform for this new breed of
content creators supercharging workflows
with RTX gpus over 110 RTX accelerated
apps dozens of sdks and Studio drivers
to deliver continual performance updates
the heartbeat of the studio platform is
found in Nvidia Omniverse where creators
can connect those accelerated apps and
collaborate in real time
3D creators use many specialized design
and content creation tools to complete
projects those tools don't easily
interact with one another making it hard
for artists to iterate quickly or bring
their projects and assets from tool to
Tool Nvidia Omniverse is a collaboration
platform enabling artists to connect
their favorite tools from Adobe Autodesk
Unreal Engine side effects and more
creators see the aggregated scene
instantly come together without lengthy
Import and Export Cycles changes happen
in real time across the connected apps
whether a single artist working in
multiple apps simultaneously or a team
contributing their individual elements
from around the globe Omniverse is based
on universal scene description which
provides a Common Language between
popular 3D design tools powered by
Nvidia RTX Omniverse supercharges
creativity with Advanced Materials AI
tools physx for easy visual effects and
real-time 4K Ray tracing powered by
dlss3 let's take a look at six freelance
creators using their favorite 3D tools
RTX Studio laptops new GeForce RTX Ada
gpus and Omniverse nucleus Cloud to
build a scene together
hey everybody thanks for jumping into
today's collab where's everybody coming
from I'm in London I'm in Florida Vegas
Toronto
wow cool all right well I was thinking
we could do an experimental short film
in Omniverse using some uh assets we
have on hand but first things first we
need to get some characters into the
scene oh I've got a couple of characters
here's 3D and figgy what do we all think
amazing that's so cool what uh what did
you build those in wrapping I made 3D
and shapes XR and figgy and Maya but
they're all essentially drag and drop
now because they're in USD man amazing
yeah I love uh 3D have you ever thought
about putting any kind of additional
textures on her yeah I was just working
substance painter I've got some knitted
textures I can apply real quick has that
updated for you beautiful
perfect
how awesome right if you want some more
cap on 3D
oh yes please that'll be fun oh Jay what
are you using well I'm using accents
right now
wow so cool nice that's awesome
you have this uh background I made in
blender what do you guys think of this
love it that one's brilliant yeah yeah
rendered in really fast yeah RTX is
insane oh Pekka what do you think of the
lighting though looking good looking
good but maybe it could be a little bit
more epic let's bring some storm a super
dramatic uh I have this Houdini rain Sim
here I'll add it wow that's so cool
that's just brilliant excellent uh what
if they escape the storm what do you
guys think of that
okay but how they gonna do that
maybe that balloon over there yeah the
balloon where did that come from
okay we should probably get out of here
uh I think we just took toy Jensen's
balloon so we're taking off in this
Bloom but where are they going we could
take them higher with some steam testers
I can add it in omnograph because I have
the 40 90 so it renders particles really
well okay fantastic how about we take
them even higher then like into space or
something love it okay so now this space
adventure that's it oh perfect actually
shengue has a satellite which is totally
added sure please use it oh yeah oh cool
and they could go all the way to the eye
of the Jupiter to seek more storms
beautiful yeah let's do it yeah this is
amazing
new GeForce RTX 40 series gpus Power
Omniverse creative workflows with
Omniverse nucleus Cloud for cloud 3D
collaboration in free Early Access now
an Omniverse is just getting started
with the alpha blender release available
from the Omniverse launcher users can
easily generate realistic facial
expressions from an audiophile with
audio to face and optimize their blender
scene for multi-app collaboration with
Omniverse we're also excited to
introduce a new suite of AI tools and
experimental plugins using the power of
AI as the ultimate creative assistant
audio to face and audio to gesture both
generate animations from an audio file
the AI Toy Box by Nvidia research lets
you generate 3D meshes from 2D inputs
and move.ai's Omniverse plugin enables
video to animation
when we announce the Ada Lovelace
architecture we also introduced the
world to Nvidia RTX remix built on
Omniverse
easiest way to mod classic games where
AI software and Hardware come together
to enable fans to channel their
creativity and reimagine the games we
all grew up loving the modding Community
can't wait to get their hands on remix
and we've already enabled two amazing
modders to bring RTX to Portal's most
famous mod Portal Prelude preserving the
Timeless gameplay while re-lighting it
with full Ray tracing RTX remix Early
Access is coming soon
and with Nvidia Omniverse Ace Early
Access developers will be able to more
easily create intelligent interactive
avatars with the combined power of
nvidia's many AI tools let's take a look
Nvidia Omniverse Avatar Cloud engine
also known as Ace opens a new world of
possibilities for bringing avatars to
Life by combining the realistic tones of
the Nvidia Rivas speech AI with the
lifelike expressions and gestures from
animation AI like audio to face creating
the next generation of digital
interaction has never been easier Ace
lets you breathe life into a wide range
of avatars from 2D portraits driven by
your own video and 3D characters from
Top Avatar creation platforms like Ready
Player me Ace is now available for Early
Access development connecting the core
AI building blocks of Avatar
intelligence to Virtual characters built
on any engine and deployed at scale on
any public or private Cloud I can even
answer challenging questions using the
power of a large language model
together with Nvidia Omniverse Avatar
Cloud engine will make the metaverse a
smarter more engaging space for all
ending throughout our Nvidia Studio apps
Nvidia canvas allows creators to paint
with materials using simple brush
strokes and AI to quickly conceptualize
a beautiful image
with the new canvas 360 feature artists
can create panoramic scenes and Export
them into any 3D app or platform as an
environment map
these can be created and iterated upon
quickly to change background and
lighting and a 3D scene
the canvas 360 beta will be available to
download for RTX users later this
quarter
in video broadcast enhances your mic and
webcam with the latest update we are
adding eye contact to the featureless
come take a closer look
eye contact will change the position at
the speaker's eyes to appear as if
you're looking at the camera allowing
for better audience engagement
in this case allowing me to read the
script from a screen next to the camera
while I still engage with you the new
Nvidia broadcast update will be
available to all RTX users later this
month
watching video is one of the most
popular activities on PCS today ninety
percent of online videos run at 1080P or
lower while nearly half of RTX users
have higher resolution monitors this
mismatch can leave a blurry or soft
visual experience
today we're announcing RTX video super
resolution using AI to improve the
quality of internet video streaming in
two ways first by removing blocky
compression artifacts and second by
upscaling video resolution this AI
accelerated combination improves video
sharpness and Clarity on high resolution
displays
RTX video super resolution will enhance
video streamed in Chrome and Edge
browsers starting this February an RTX
30 and 40 series gpus
now let me hand it back to Jeff
thanks Stephanie gaming has grown Beyond
entertainment into the social fabric of
generations of Gamers creating has grown
Beyond photos and videos to Virtual
Worlds rendered with 3D cinematic
graphics and true to life physics and
the RTX platform is powering this growth
today we covered several topics RTX
momentum continues to build
Ray tracing and AI are defining the next
generation of content and one of our
greatest inventions dlss3 has become our
fastest adopted
Nvidia studio with Omniverse at its
heart Powers RTX remix and our new
Avatar platform Ace the 40 series
performance and power efficiency is
enabling a new class of laptops
including 14-inch gaming and creating
powerhouses
and the new 4070 tie for desktop brings
the Ada architecture down to 7.99
finally the RTX 4080 is coming to gfn
Millions more Gamers will have access to
the Ada architecture with our ultimate
membership
[Music]